directeur général adjoint de
l'exploitation vélo police bienvenue sur
ce plateau nous allons donc nous pencher
sur cette question du Vélodrome je vous
le disais en titre cette première
question à quand son ouverture on parle
de fin 2013 plus précisément en fait la
livraison de l'enceinte est effectuée le
13 décembre 2013 et l'ouverture pour le
grand public s'effectuera aux alentours
du 13 janvier où en sont les travaux
aujourd'hui vous respectez le calendrier
qui était fixé le calendrier pleinement
respecté on sera même un petit peu en
avance le temps pour nous de bien
finaliser l'ensemble des tests afin
d'assurer une livraison parfaite du
bâtiment qu'est-ce qui a été réalisé
aujourd'hui de l'extérieur en tout cas
si on s'approche un petit peu on voit
que c'est devenu assez imposant
aujourd'hui la structure est sortie de
terre à l'intérieur tout reste à faire
non à l'intérieur une grosse partie est
également déjà réalisée les tribunes
sont en place les sièges doivent être
installés on en est au stade de
l'air centrale où on coule la dalle
béton qui va accueillir les autres
activités sportives et spectacles que
celles du cyclisme donc les travaux sont
bien avancés toute la partie bureau est
également quasiment finalisée parce
qu'il n'y aura pas que du cyclisme vous
nous l'avez dit une grande partie pour
les bureaux il y aura aussi des
spectacles qui sont accueillis on va
détailler tout ça juste auparavant une
petite précision j'évoquais vélo police
vous êtes donc le représentant de vélo
police vélo police c'est quoi mais le
police c'est la société exploitation qui
aura en charge à la fois l'exploitation
commerciale la maintenance et
l'entretien du bâtiment pendant 27
années d'exploitation puisque c'est un
montage financier en partenariat public
privé on a vu l'occasion d'en parler on
va juste repréciser il y a une partie de
deux fonds publics et puis une société
privée qui s'est jointes à l'opération
exactement une société publique qui
joint l'opération pour la partie
financement privée et la gestion du
risque et l'entretien du bâtiment ce qui
coûte en général le plus cher sur ce
type d'installation les travaux qui se
poursuivent avant cette livraison au 13
décembre de cette année l'étape
importante aujourd'hui c'était le
coulage d'une dalle en béton le cœur de
ce vélo de Rome Anthony était présent
Elodie moi négalement voici les images
le point sur ce chantier à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
il leur reste encore 8 mois pour être
prêt en décembre prochain le vélodrome
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le futur
Clairefontaine du cyclisme français doit
ouvrir officiellement ses portes ce 23
avril une étape décisive a débuté la
dalle de béton de l'air centrale est en
train d'être coulée sur plus de 2700
mètres carrés cet espace est essentiel
car il va servir de base au constructeur
de la piste au-dessus de notre tête on
est à peu près 1000 tonnes de d'acier ce
qui est quand même assez important c'est
quoi c'est pas très très courant même en
Île-de-France et cette charpente va être
terminée depuis maintenant quelques
semaines la couverture également est en
passe d’être terminé voilà on commence
un peu à voir la forme finale du délai
de Rome dans la configuration
compétition près de 5000 spectateurs
pour vous garnir les gradins du vélo
Drôme les responsables du chantier
espèrent le livret clé en main à
l'automne ou la touche finale sera
évidemment la piste en bois il est prévu
que le constructeur de la piste arrive à
partir de début août donc les toutes
premières lattes seront posées à partir
du 12 août très précisément en tout cas
c'est comme ça qu'on l'a vu dans le
calendrier et donc la fin de la piste
c'est fin septembre pour ce qui est de
la partie plus visible le vélodrome est
en train de revêtir sa robe finale le
bardage extérieur juste derrière
d'autres équipes sont en train d'établir
les fondations de la future piste de BMX
au total 140 personnes travaillent sur
le chantier la naissance de ce complexe
sportif inédit coûtera près de 70
millions d'euros
non alors en fait le projet est très
très bien ficelé financièrement ce qui
ne fait pas peser un risque sur un
risque d'exploitation réel on est
vraiment ensuite dans une qualité
d'exploitation diversifiée pour rendre
cette enceinte accessible à tous donc
effectivement il y aura du concert
spectacle même si ce n'est pas le cœur
de métier et le cœur de fonction de
cette enceinte et principalement
d'autres activités physiques et
sportives au sein de la reine et puis il
y a une fédération qui va s'y installer
c'est la Fédération Française de
Cyclisme alors à son siège à l'équipe de
France aura son centre d'entraînement
également l'équipement parmi les
différents équipements on peut aussi
s'intéresser à au BMX parce que le BMX
sera représenté aussi oui oui alors
c'est une des rares enceintes au sens où
il est ce vélo drone mais à la fois le
Clairefontaine du vélo capable
d'accueillir l'équipe de France au
quotidien mais aussi une arène à sportif
capable d'accueillir du spectacle et
puis un gymnase quasiment puisque on va
avoir de l'activité sportive quotidienne
accessible à tout le public des cinq
continents et il y aura aussi une
possibilité d'hébergement tout à fait
tout est un peu les chiffres qu'on peut
avancer ce sont les capacités alors
d'ici à fin 2015 il y a un hôtel en
construction 2 et 3 étoiles qui va à peu
près héberger 180 chambres d'hôtel et
puis un complexe d'accueil jeunes actifs
aux alentours qui pour accueillir à peu
près 700 personnes vous avez le
sentiment que c'est très attendu ce
vélodrome parce qu'on en a parlé
beaucoup avant sa livraison c'est un
projet qui remonte à la candidature de
Paris en 2012 pour les JO alors 2012 est
passé le vélo donc va voir le jour c'est
c'est une enceinte qui est très attendue
à double titre vous avez toutes les
anciennes générations pour qui
la dernière histoire du vélo de Rome est
représentée à travers le veldive et qui
voit en ce vélo drone le nouveau veldive
et puis toutes les nouvelles générations
qui cherchent des enceintes
à jour je dirais au maximum de leurs
capacité de l'accueil de leur qualité
d'accueil pour pouvoir organiser leur
activité et porter leur activité dans
une autre dimension et cet Arena sportif
ce vélodrome le permettra ça sera en
plus aussi pour l'activité économique de
50 ans en Yvelines des alentours
clairement je pense que c'est c'est un
plus économique pour les entreprises qui
voudront s'a au Vélodrome en tant que
partenaire pour disposer d'un espace de
présentation produit de RP de enfin de
relation publique pardon et de Edinson
tea interne pour leur salarié leur
comité d'entreprise c'est vraiment une
boîte à outils assez intéressante on
peut imaginer qu'il sera rapidement à
son à son plein rendement cette
équipement des sons d'ouverture et ça
très sollicité très très demandé par
exemple les entreprises comme vous
l'avez mentionné on est déjà très
sollicité puisqu'il y a une grosse
partie de la programmation 2014 qui est
déjà acté avec presque une trentaine de
dates sur des sur des manifestations
très variées sportives associatives
c'était quelques-unes ou c'est encore
confidentielles c'est rien n'est figé
donc c'est un peu c'est un peu prématuré
mais vraiment des choses assez
éclectiques très très intéressantes
venez nous en parler forcément on parle
de tous ces points positifs on peut
aussi forcément parler des points
positifs pour le développement du
cyclisme en France il y a de grands
sportifs qui vont venir s'entraîner ça
peut booster aussi le cyclisme en France
je pense que ça peut le booster dans la
mesure où ça permet de le structurer
et surtout aussi de rassembler sur un
seul et même site diverses pratiques
cyclistes qui sont par définition un
petit peu
éparpillées entre la route le VTT le
cyclo-cross le BMX fait appel à des
populations et des pratiques un peu
différentes le Centre national du
cyclisme le vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines permettra de
rassembler l'ensemble de ses disciplines
sur le même c'est juste avant que vous
nous donniez pour conclure le calendrier
un petit peu pour la suite des travaux
j'ai une dernière question il y a eu
plusieurs recours qui ont été déposés
par un collectif qui s'intitule
Vélodrome pour jouer sur ce mot de vélo
de Drôme qui avait déposé pas mal de
recours sur les constructions vélo
police aussi et donc avaient décidé de
se retourner contre ce collectif et
demander 3 millions 7 à 9 opposants pour
recours abusif et fautif où on est cette
procédure sont les différentes
procédures le recours n'est toujours pas
instruit donc en attendant le chantier
avance et nous attendons une instruction
prochaine sur le dossier ça veut dire
que si une instruction que la justice se
penche en faveur de Vélodrome la
finalisation du Vélodrome est remise en
cause je peux pas je peux pas vous
confirmer aujourd'hui il faudra il
faudra viser à ce moment là ce serait
vraiment très très dommageable pour
l'ensemble de la population je pense par
rapport à la qualité de cette enceinte
en tout cas les travaux se poursuivent
vous pouvez le voir si vous êtes sur le
secteur de 50 ans en Yvelines si vous
passez à proximité de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les prochaines
étapes importantes les livraisons de la
piste par exemple il y a la livraison de
la piste il y a aussi la face que les
gens ne peuvent pas voir actuellement
qui est la pose du bardage extérieur
donc de la partie métallique cuivrée qui
vient vraiment habiller l'ensemble du
Vélodrome qui va lui donner une vraie
une vraie identité visuelle donc ça
c'est une étape importante
l'élévation de la toiture du BMX
puisqu'on sera sur la première piste de
BMX couverte en Europe ce qui est ce qui
est aussi une performance nationale et
internationale voilà sont les
principales échéances avant l'hiver et
la livraison finale du vélo drone merci
à vous pensez précision nous reviendrons
bien sûr sur ce chantier du vélo de
Romain Montigny-le-Bretonneux notamment
lors des prochaines éditions du 7 8
sport vous le savez c'est le lundi à
18h30 en direct avec Anthony Reich
toutes les informations aussi sont à
retrouver bien sûr sur notre site
internet